welcome to the Python by immersion
tutorial here at PyCon 2018 thank you
everyone for coming I have been doing
this tutorial in various formats in
various places for almost a decade
this is actually my 11th time teaching
some kind of tutorial at PyCon taught
computer science at university for a
while so i've got a fair amount of
teaching experience in sort of scattered
areas so hopefully this will work if it
doesn't I certainly want to hear
feedback on the survey link or just in
person because it helps that the
tutorial get better so you're gonna be
drinking from a firehose
so I'm gonna show you about eleven
hundred lines of code in under three
hours and talk about a fair number of
them especially early on somewhat slowly
and then we'll get faster
don't please try not to get discouraged
if you don't understand everything I go
over I think you'll understand most of
it but some stuff you won't and that's
okay definitely do not try to memorize
what I'm showing you right so the the
title of the tutorial Python by
immersion is like learning a language by
immersion right you don't start with
well here's the grammar and here are the
tenses of the verbs and here are the
those kinds of things instead it's just
like you just start listening and you
start absorbing your brain starts
absorbing in ways you don't even
understand and and that's my goal here
so I'm going to show you a broad
overview of the language and my hope is
three weeks from now when you find
yourself needing to do a particular
thing in Python you'll go you'll be able
to say with some level of confidence but
you're not sure why oh yeah I'm pretty
sure you I can do that in Python pretty
easily even if you don't remember what I
showed you today somewhere in your brain
will be the knowledge that you have a
sense for what Python is about it and
you have a sense for the kinds of stuff
you can go looking for okay I'm gonna
start the law the first 20 minutes about
fairly slow and a little bit pedantic
trying to explain certain things about
Python that are very different from many
other programming languages especially a
number the ones that you are coming from
and that all has to do with objects and
names and variables
yeah so and the rhythm is that I will
talk for a bit and then show you some
code and then I'll give you time to work
on some exercises during which time I
will wander around and if I answer
questions when I'm wandering around I'll
probably just answer them one on one and
then summarize them at the end when I
come back up here and we'll go through
the same exercise you just did but a
little bit quicker and adding the
explanations especially where people had
questions feel free to stop me with
questions raise your hand sometimes I'll
say ask me later or I'll get to it later
sometimes I'll answer it right then okay
any questions before we get going okay
so here's the form of this tutorial that
this is what most of us gonna be like
I'm gonna show you lines of code and
talk about what's going on first of all
I'll tell you what version I happen to
be writing and then I'm going to talk
about how objects get created in Python
and this would be kind of slow but it's
really important to understand to get
the right mental model of how this works
so I'm going to talk about this line for
about two minutes I'm gonna type the
number one it hit enter so this is the
read eval print loop you can tell that
by the three a little greater than sign
to the chevron there at the read eval
print loop when you type an expression
python parses it compiles it into byte
code not into machine code but into
bytecode it then executes sit and if
it's got a value if that expression has
a value other than none it will display
that value on standard output so it'll
print the value the expression okay so
there it just did it it evaluated the
the the character which is the digit one
and it figured out that that's an
integer literal that's called because
you literally are typing the integer
into the prompt there and you could put
these all these lines in code too the
only difference between there the read
eval print loop the repple and what you
what happens when you run your code is
it doesn't automatically print out all
the expressions the reading of L print
loop prints the one if you write a
script or code it's not going to print
the one unless you use the print
function but what actually happens when
I typed the 3.14 in this example by the
way that far numbers on the far right
those are just line numbers too
be on track and i can go back quickly so
when python sees a literal like this
this one's a floating-point literal it
creates an object which represents the
literal so let's go back to the one
there and just do that one because so
I'm used to talking about so when I type
the 1 and hit enter
Python goes off and it creates an object
in memory an integer on most your
machines takes about 64 bits of memory
about 8 bytes the object that Python
creates is more like 30 or 40 bytes big
it's huge
by computer terms relative to the amount
of memory that's actually storing the
integer so you have this big object that
has all sorts of information in it of
which the 1 is a small piece the other
stuff is what type it is what its super
classes are what its document is a whole
bunch of stuff in there how many names
are bound to it etc ok so every time you
do that so this is in contrast to the
way you're used to thinking about
variables in Python and any language
most people think of variables as a box
within memory location in memory and if
I assign a variable the number 3 I write
over the bits that are in that box with
new bits and I get the 3 in there and if
I say that variables 417 then I erased
those bits and write over it with 17
that's not what's happening in Python in
Python emphasized 1 it creates an object
and makes I refer to it if I say I
equals 17 it creates a different object
it makes I refer to that instead and
I'll repeat that a few times in the next
section as well let's just look at how
you create stuff in Python so I can
create integer literals floating point
literals string literals with single
quotes or double quotes round brackets
or parentheses around a list of literals
or a list of anything a sequence of
anything gives me a couple sometimes
pronounced tuple and it's an immutable
list is the way a good way to think
about it if you put square brackets
instead of round brackets it's almost
the same except it's mutable so one you
can change easily one you can never
change once you've created a tuple you
can't pull things out you can't change
elements in it a list you can change it
all you want and there's some reasons
for why there are both that aren't that
important
not going to really mention you got a
second
oh sorry wrong code okay great all that
work and now hold on a second here
okay so when you create objects in
Python they have a single value a single
type they have attributes they have one
more base classes if you understand what
classes are it's not going to slow you
down much today it has every option has
a single ID and every object has a name
usually almost all objects have a name
and many times objects have more than
one name those names live in different
namespaces so I might have two names in
my current namespace and I'll explain
what namespaces are soon you might have
more than one name in the same namespace
much more often you'll have names in
different namespaces like you might
import a module and then access an
attribute of it and you might have names
in multiple places so let's uh sorry all
right I'll get the hang of this soon
okay so let's explore this a little bit
so what's gonna happen here this is
about one of about ten times I'm gonna
slow down and just say it the same way
Python sees the one it creates an object
it sends that object then looks up the
name type and finds another object what
happens to be a function a callable type
is a class or a function but it's
callable like a function is it then
takes that object and sends it off to
that other object and executes it
because it's got the round brackets it
does a call it executes that function
that function does something with it and
returns a new object which is the class
int the class of which one is an
instance is its own object so classes
are objects in Python everything in
Python is an object and then it tries to
represent that class well instead of you
know right showing you the C code that
implemented or the Python code that
implemented it it says well it's a class
and it's got its name it because it it's
got it it's trying to show you what it
is but it's hard to show what it is
because you can't type this back into
the prompt and get the class int okay
3.14 s type floats there's string for a
string STR the type of that tuple is
tuple there's the list objects have
attributes so this looks up the name
true finds an object and then tries to
access dunder doc so this is a
underscore doc double underscore which
we say instead of saying double
underscore true double underscore we say
our start doc we say dunder doc so if
you hear me say dunder doc it means
double underscore on both sides and
those are attributes in Python that are
sure behind the scenes you're welcome to
use them you but there's sort of more
implementation side than user side and
you can see that that has an attribute
which is this long string that explains
how a doc works here's a string object
and we ask access its upper attribute
and we get back built-in method upper
blah blah blah so it's a method methods
are like functions but instead of
calling them with parameters or
arguments you call them on an object and
pass extra arguments so a method is
always a call made on or to an object so
this method when you call it operates on
that okay and when I say operates
doesn't mean it actually necessarily
changes it it might just return a new
one or a different version or how big it
is right so here I'm gonna check is that
string is this attribute of this object
callable yes it is so I can call it like
a function so I will call it like a
function here I just access the
attribute now I'm gonna call it like a
function and it's like I'm asking the
spam object give me an uppercase version
of yourself and so it returns a new
object which is an uppercase string spam
okay objects have base classes the
inspect module is a good way to look out
so spam is an instance of string which
is a subclass of object true is a type
bool which is a subclass of int which is
a subclass of object so if you're
familiar with classes everything in
Python the superclass of all the objects
in Python is the type object which just
has a few rudimentary things that it can
do every object in Python has an ID the
ID of the object that gets created when
Python sees the three and creates that
integer object that represents the three
with some long number the only thing
you're guaranteed is that numbers you
across between like every object has
unique ID other than that you don't need
to worry about what that means and so
here in cpython which is the version the
implementation of Python most people run
it's written in C that's why it's called
C Python it's actually a memory address
which is kind of interesting but that's
not guaranteed to always be true and
it's not true in all implementations of
Python here's the other way to create
object so that's all so far all I've
done is is directly created objects with
literals or called functions to get them
back in general you usually call other
objects to create object or get access
to objects so ABS is a built-in function
it is callable this object it's gonna
get back a different object in this case
right int is a built-in type 3 was an
instance of int it's actually call 'evil
and every class is callable because when
you instantiate a class you do it like a
function call in this case it kind of
functions it in sort of feels like a
function that when you call it converts
whatever you pass it to an int like that
okay so let's talk about names more
carefully
I just restarted my Python to clear my
name space which makes things a little
easier
so there's built-ins which is a name
that shows up in my name space in this
the way I'm running Python here let me
create a little function here that you
don't need to worry about how that works
when I say a equals 300 I'm gonna add
this name to my current namespace and
I'm gonna take that object that got
created when the 300 was interpreted and
make a reference to it so if you want to
say a is a variable and it holds the
value 300 it sits in terms of computer
programming it's a little bit misleading
especially if you don't have the right
mental model for how it works and and
even if you've only ever learned Python
you just people talk about variables
this way
they talk about the box into which you
put values so I prefer at least when I'm
teaching to use the language that's
standard in the Python documentation
which is the name a is bound to the
object 300 so this is a name binding and
the name lives in a namespace okay once
you've bound the name a to the 300 then
you can see in my namespace I didn't
have anything before now I have a name a
there's a representation of the the
objects what it looks like and here's
where actually lives in memory its ID so
now I can type a and hit enter and
Python says oh that looks like a string
but it doesn't have the quotes around it
but it's a valid identifier it starts
with a letter uppercase or lowercase it
has some number of letters uppercase or
lowercase or maybe an underscore in it
with no breaks that therefore that looks
like an identifier I'm gonna assume it's
a name I'm gonna look it up and try to
find it if it does it gets the object
back and tries to show it to you that's
why you get the 300 okay I'm not gonna
go this slow the whole time don't worry
but thinking about this way is really
important that's why I'm taking the time
now right so actually had a mistake here
that I didn't notice which is I forgot
to do this so I've restarted the
interpreter the name space was cleared
if I type a now it's gonna go look in
the name space because it looks like an
identifier it's not gonna find it really
I thought I restarted the interpreter
there we go now if I type a and hit
enter I get a name error okay so if you
type a name and it's not in the
namespace it can't find it then it gives
you an error well how did it find abs
and true well that's different
those are sort of built-ins that are
hiding behind the namespace so this area
you get name error and when you see
errors like this read them the first ten
of you like this is kind of complicated
what's this all mean but once you get in
the habit of reading errors they
actually come in really handy sometimes
often you'll find that if you read the
error after reading ten or twenty of
them you get to the point where it oh
actually that doesn't give me a clue to
what I did wrong so in this case trace
back if this were a function calling a
function calling a function you'd have
that whole call stack in the trace back
in here it's a single line because I'm
running at the interactive prompt the
repple and it's saying it's it was
running this file well it's not a file
it's the repple so it calls the file
console it's at line one well obviously
there was only one line and it wasn't in
a module because I was just running at
the repple but then it gives the error
so name error is the name of the
exception it's this is a common name
it's it common it's usually uppercase
lowercase camelcase
and it's named air or something air or
something here and then it tells you
exactly what it was named a is not
defined okay so a little diversion there
about reading names okay so let's go
back and do we got the a and there's the
300 okay so I've got that I can access
it and what if I hit save type A equals
400 so what's going to happen is Python
sees the 400 goes off and creates an
integer object representing the integer
400 it then says okay I'm going to add
this to the name space well actually
it's already in the name space so it's
just going to change the value so name
spaces in Python are like dictionaries
dictionaries are mappings from keys to
values and it's a common data structure
in Python that we'll explore later key
value pairs so the key is a the values
400 in a dictionary you have to name the
dictionary use square brackets put a
quote around the a close quote square
bracket names that short does all that
for you is another way to think about it
it's like a dictionary that doesn't you
just
type the characters right away and it
assumes you mean a key in that namespace
dictionary okay so here it's just gonna
change the value that's already in the
dictionary for the name a in the
namespace right so we can see that
namespace changed a is still there but
different value different location so
what this does is it looks up the name a
gets back an object and then adds a new
name to the namespace B which refers to
that same object okay so it's not
copying the value from A to B in the
traditional variable computer science or
computer programming sense it's just
putting two names in the namespace that
point to the same object okay and if I
look at B it says 400 is 400 and you can
see that they are at the same address so
these are actually the same 400 because
they're it's one object that represents
the 402 names the other way to think
about names as being bound to objects is
to think about post Asst right so if I
have a post it and I write Stuart on it
and put it right there that's a name for
me as Stuart if I write dad and put it
on a post it stick it on me or in some
namespace at home with my kids that name
is the name for me write in a different
namespace someone else's family when you
put the name mom on you you're gonna you
know if you're a mother then your kids
will understand that name but in our
family it's like a different namespace
mom means a different thing it's bound
to a different object okay so think of
post Asst on an a on an object and you
can have multiple ones just like we have
an A and a B here C equals 400 okay so
interesting now we have a and B they all
have the same value these two actually
are at the same address so we know those
are the same object this one's in a
different address that's up to Python
whether or not it creates the introduced
at the same address are different and
there it actually pre-allocate some
sometimes it'll it'll reuse an object
sometimes it won't in the case of
integers and strings it can reuse them
because they're immutable you can't
change the value of one it's always
so this is getting sort of so I'm going
slow to explain names and namespaces and
objects I'm also showing you some of
these behind the scene details like
where the memory is just because that
helps you understand what's going on at
that level right so if you want to
program well in Python it helps to know
a little bit about what's going on
underneath the hood or behind the
curtain if you want to know how to drive
a car really well it helps to know a
little bit about the engine works if you
want to ride a bike earlier you know etc
so so knowing that the next layer down a
little bit of it is helpful I think so
idea is one is the way you can get these
addresses is is the way you check in
Python if - I'm gonna say it wrong if
two objects are the same well if two
objects are the same they are the same
object so what it really is checking is
if the name a is bound to the same
object as the name B are those two names
the names for the same object that's
what is means it does not mean really
really equal alright some languages
you've got equal double equal triple
equal that's not what it means and there
are some edge cases where you'll
actually get in trouble if you assume
that is is the same as equal yes
question
yep what if I do that next no I don't
well now it's gonna fail let me show you
oh sorry it's going well the answer is
yes II would
it would sorry so SB was true it's now
false because I went on and moved
backwards and if you said a is C you
would get the answer false so here I'm
going to change the I'm going to change
a to be ABC you can talk like that
remember what we're actually doing is
we're creating a new object representing
the string ABC and binding a that was
looking at the 400 on binding it to now
refer to the string ABC so ivory binding
the name all right so now if I look he
is still 400 show names shows me I've
got his bound to that B is bound to that
C is bound to that these are two
different objects usually you don't need
to worry about this but when you do need
to worry about it you really need to
understand it and it really matters a
lot in rare cases well relatively rare
in some some of you are doing pandas for
example there are cases where whether or
not the objects are the same object or
if they're just equal makes a big
difference in terms of performance
sometimes you just want to use the same
one again because to reallocate millions
of rows is going to be inefficient okay
we're almost past the slow boring name
stuff here del a what do you think that
does it takes the post it off and throws
it away it doesn't take all the post-its
off just the one that was the a it
doesn't do anything with the object the
object is not deleted when you called la
right when is an obsolete 'add well when
all the names when all the post-its have
been pulled off the object and there's
no more references to it then there's no
way you can it can be reached from any
line of code then Python goes and cleans
it up and that's called garbage
collection
and that's very convenient for
programmers to not have to worry about
that and and in languages where you do
have to worry about that memory leaks
are always a problem unless you're very
careful or there's a strong language
support board so now we've just got BNC
left a is gone del B del C now it's
empty nothing in the namespace just if I
said their cases were knowing when you
mean equality and when you mean is
basically the only time you want to use
is in common practice is in a function
when you're checking to see if a
non-default parameter was passed or are
you most passed and I'll show you that
later and so you'll often see at the
being a function if r1 is none well
that's the right thing to do otherwise
you almost always want to use equality
instead of years here's proof okay
that's interesting so I said I equal ten
Jake Walton turns out that when Python
saw this ten it didn't go create a new
object it went and found the one that
already existed that represents the
integer ten and so you can see here I
mean there's the comma here means please
evaluate these both these expressions is
actually an implied tuple I'm saying are
they equal are they the same name are
they are they two names for the same
object yes and yes and you can see
they're at the same address however oh
in here I equal J equals 500 this is
Python syntax that says please bind both
these names to that object at the same
time or right after each other so it's
actually here you're guaranteed that
whatever J was bound to I is going to
get bound to the same object and you can
see that they're equal and they're the
same object yeah
but this one does not so in this case if
I create a fire if I say to Python I
want to use the integer 500 it goes and
creates a new one and you say it again
it goes and creates a different new one
in a different location and so these are
equal but they are not two names for the
same object they are two names for two
different objects and why it does it
this way it's for efficiency reasons
integers from about minus 5 to plus 256
are commonly used and so pre allocating
them saves
memory whereas other integers aren't
used that often so it doesn't
pre-allocate so that's behind the scenes
what's going on the lesson here is use
equals almost always when you want to
check for equality use is extremely
rarely okay so import math what it does
is it asks Python to go find the library
named math pull it into memory so that
it can actually execute parts of it and
then puts the name math in the current
namespace so it bound the name math to
that module now I can access the
attribute of that object like math is
not his name referring to an object it
has an attribute called nan and if I get
that back it shows me as nan some of you
for me with this it's not a number it's
a representation of something it's not a
number it's type is floats so here's the
counter example that's kind of weird in
this case they are the same object but
they are not equal to each other right
and that's just the weirdness of man and
it's useful to have that behavior so the
nan object is not equal to itself but
it's it is the same object okay just
driving home the point here use equal
okay so now I'm gonna let you do some
exercises I this section Kay members I
hi long as I'll bring it up and see for
myself so I'll give you a few minutes to
do the exercises when you do the
exercises I encourage you to I've tried
to make them easy to type so a lot of
times I use short names and short stuff
whenever possible I
encourage you not just to type them in
hit enter I encourage you to type it and
then think about what's gonna happen
here right okay it says I you know for
example it says okay like here when you
when you type this into the interactive
prompt type I before you hit err figure
out what's gonna happen what is going to
happen when you hit enter on this okay
and if you can't figure that's okay go
ahead and do it but but try to figure
out ahead of time and I will wander
around and answer questions and then
we'll move on
usually when about half the class has
done the exercises I make them long
enough and hard enough near the end that
I try to keep everybody happy ly doing
exercises but when you're about halfway
through you've gotten as much as you
really need to do to move on any
questions
so if you haven't gotten the exercise
yet there second of the bottom line here
HTTP bitly pike on 28 - immersion or or
it was the event he was emailed out to
you about three hours ago as well if you
you know bring up a dropbox screen that
shows three files you can download one
of them are just click download and
download the whole zip
but you can't use locals when I use dirt
the other form which is to pass it an
object stop attending exercises is that
clear it's like
so when you get to the numbers we have
to talk to number so you did a little
bit with lists
okay so how many people are done don't
feel bad if you're not finishing someone
else's usually we'll move on okay so now
I'm going to go through the exercises
which means even those of you who didn't
finish you're gonna see new things
they're hard to learn and it's your
questions you might have as you're going
thank you okay so I'm gonna now go
through the exercises that you just did
and those of you who didn't finish you
won't have to worry about not finishing
because you're gonna see what I'm doing
so I named error
how many predicted that correctly that's
pretty good
more than half didn't and that's normal
you know I'm making you think I'm gonna
intentionally frustrate you a little bit
to make you think and hope that doesn't
go overboard because thinking about what
the computers gonna do is is a really
effective way especially when you're
diagnosing a problem just look at the
codes okay what's Python gonna do in
this situation it's a really effective
way to find bugs and figure out why
something's not doing with it
you think it should be doing because
python can't read your mind so and you
can see there is no I in their namespace
once I've bound I to the object integer
one then when I type I don't get a name
error I get the value back and you could
see that the I got added to the
namespace it's an int now J and I are
two names that are bound to the same
object and I I know that not because of
the value but because J equals I it's
going to by and J to the same object
that is bound to so that's not
implementation specific that's
guaranteed by Python and so they are
going to be the same two names for the
same object so this is a list we create
here with two names
they those two names the object is the
same so it looks the same and you can
see the M and the end names that got put
into the namespace you didn't do either
restart like I did so you'll probably
have a li in there as well and maybe
some other names this is the syntax in
Python to access element at index one
Python lists and tuples start at index
zero so the first element is called zero
and that's not just to be frustrating
that's because it actually reduces bugs
there's some interesting papers from
many decades ago talking about
zero-based indexing is better than one
based indexing it makes a lot of
calculations easier once you get used to
it so what this does this is actually
not a name assignments right so earlier
I said you know M equals in the list
that's assigning or binding the name and
the name M and the name end to an object
in this case this is actually a request
to the object that M refers to to change
index element one to be that object
instead I'm saying your request is like
message passing the old metaphor for
object-oriented programming with methods
right so that's so this so this object
tries to change itself the M object the
object M refers to tried to tries to
change itself it say oh let me go find X
1 the second element and whatever was
there get rid of it and put it B in its
place oh sorry
and whatever it was referring to at
element 1 make it refer to something
else instead
right I'm sort of switching between the
talking about variables colloquially and
the way python is doing it and so now
you look at em and you've got 1b and 3
so if I ask if I asked the object that M
is bound to to change L index 1 to B
will n the name n the object it refers
to will it also show up has changed the
answer is yes because it's the same
object so we asked the object we didn't
ask the M or the end the object doesn't
even know its name it just knows it's a
list okay all right
any questions on the lab all right we go
love it faster
look fast you know okay so let's just
explore numbers a little bit
oh okay one - yeah that doesn't really
make one sense - one means negative one
so - you can either subtract or say
something is negative and here's you get
here's how you get a syntax error and it
shows you the line that failed and it
shows you where in the line of failed
that's what that little hat or carrot
means it says at that character is when
I couldn't figure out what you meant
that's reassuring actually but I can't
assign too literal I can't make the
literal one have a different value it's
always going to mean an integer one in
Python okay there's equality there's the
inequality that not equal
used to have the other one less than
greater than as a not equal that I think
got removed in Python three so it's
always this one instead is one less than
two yes is one less than or equal to one
yes it's equal to one so it is less than
or equal to one is one greater than 2 no
we can do math that's pretty good
1/2 in Python 3 gives you 0.5 that was a
big change for Python 2 fixed one of the
problems with design problems from
Python that was figured out to be a
design problem long after the fact this
is floor division which basically does
an integer divide rounds down okay this
is a modular modulo operator or
otherwise known as clock arithmetic
right if it's how many times does 3 go
into 9 3 and how many are left over will
0 it divides evenly so there's the 0
whereas if you divide that way you get 1
left over it's the remainder so I double
click there int is callable I can pass 2
to the int callable and get back the
same thing if it takes it'll take a
float it'll take a float that's not
equal to an integer and he'll truncate
it it won't round it it'll convert from
strings
but it draws the line somewhere and says
uh sorry that was a float
you want me to convert that string
that's a float to an int it's not a
string int it's a string float it stops
there because you wouldn't want to do
that one by mistake okay
this air is kind of interesting value
error so we've seen name error and
syntax error well now we have value
error invalid literal which is the
string literal for int which is what we
call with base 10 so it's maybe there's
a clue there that you can actually use
other bases and of course it's not going
to magically figure out that you speak
English and want to turn that into a
number so it's try it's pretty strict in
terms of and narrow in terms of how it
interprets it okay float two will
convert from int to float so convert
from strings including floating-point
numbers this will give us another error
0 division error at what line can we add
types that are different types sometimes
floats and hits you can write equals one
yeah yeah we've seen that a plus one so
look up the name hey in the name space
find the object it reprobate refers to
or is bound to which is represented like
that
go find or create another object which
represents the integer one add those two
numbers together to create a new object
which is going to be an integer two and
display it right so now what is a what
is a bound to that's still one I didn't
change it all right and now I can bind
so it showed me the two and then it
stopped using it didn't have a name
anymore so following give it a name I
put the name binding in front this
assignment here it is going to change
what a is bound to right it's not going
to change what's in the box a because
that's not the way Python does it but
it's going to look up the one
create another one add them together
create a two and then bind a two so in
this line it looked up a as one and now
binds it to two
ok so it's changing that namespace a
plus equal one is lets us do that or
something very similar to that all in
one line and we get a three this
operators actually its own it's a it's
not just syntactic sugar for this this
actually tries to ask this object to
change itself in place but integers
can't change their value lists can by
change their contents or what they refer
to
if it can't change itself then it falls
back and does that so that's a little
bit behind the scenes are a little bit
more depth of what actually is going on
this you'll see you may be familiar with
some c++ doesn't exist in python that's
a conscious choice okay
these are pretty straightforward I think
oh okay let's do some math so sine PI /
- name error there is no sign name
available to us and Python we didn't put
it in the namespace and it's not part of
the built-ins there are about 50
built-ins that you get for free that
don't show up when you do adder but they
are accessible sine is not one of them
right so it's not in this sort of hidden
namespace and it's not the ones that
created import math as I showed you
before
we'll add math as the name to the
current namespace and make it a bind it
to the math module which has a whole
bunch of attributes including sine and
pi so will this work now is the name
sign to find in my namespace no only the
name math got defined in ieee name space
right so there's the math that got added
if I look at the attributes of that
object there are lots of them including
some over there sine and where pi is
there it is right so I can type this and
it will work all right and again what's
going on here Python looks up this
object asks that object for this name
and get
back the attribute which is a
floating-point object representing pi it
goes and creates a floating-point number
representing - it does the division
takes that object sends it off to
whatever to look up here you get the
idea right so we get the number you can
do from math import sine PI whatever you
want and what that will do is it will go
find this module which already was
imported so it doesn't reinforce it from
the disk it just says oh I've already
got I know I already know about that one
because I did an import of it earlier
and I'll go look inside it for those two
objects and instead of putting math in
the namespace it puts sine and pi into
the namespace right so sine refers to
math dot sine now and pi refers to math
dot pi now I can just say sine PI over 2
and it works in general this syntax is
not recommended when you're writing code
that's going to live for a long time and
lots of people are maintaining because
it doesn't take very much effort to
write that over that and then it's very
clear to the reader exactly this is very
clear to the reader what's going on oh
you talking about the sign from the math
module not the sign from the numpy
module or something like that yes
does this take a performance hit because
it has to load the whole module no so
when you load a module it loads the
whole module unless the in a few cases
the module is smart and will sort of
auto load certain pieces but something
like the math that just loads it in
because it's fast to get it in so it's
pretty rare that you have really large
complicated modules that incremental e
load and when they do they that's
usually hidden from you help in is a
built in function you can pass it an
object not a name it's Python looks up
this looks up this it's an object passes
it off to help and based on that object
help says oh I'm going to tell you about
that object and so if that's true how
did help know to use the word math and
the word sign was because the object
itself knows its own name I told you
objects don't know their names in a few
cases they do modules classes functions
when they are created the name is stuck
in there are referenced the name is
stuck in there so that the documentation
works get more implementation feel than
you need maybe but some of you so what I
when I serve do those little digressions
like that if you don't get it don't
worry about it we'll just keep going
okay your turn to do a few exercises
with numbers
okay let's move along so a number of you
that you noticed in this set of
exercises a couple things one is I
introduced new things in the exercises
and that was intentional alright
ai-ai-ai-aight I'm not going to do what
Knuth didn't offer you double a dollar
you know the first person who finds a
bug I give you a dollar the second
person I'll give you two for but I'm
almost positive there are no errors left
in the exercises they're all intentional
so when you get an error it's because I
wanted you to get the air and look at it
and think about it when you see an R in
front of string I want you think well
what is that can I figure out what it is
just by looking at the code oh and then
I'll explain it in the exercises so so
so yes get a little bit frustrated
enough to make you think harder but if
it really bugs you you know if you're
gonna hate me for it well tell me
afterwards no I'll clean it up because I
don't want to be too frustrating camera
what else think that was the only thing
I noticed different terms are the
questions that we're coming around but
let's look at these so great integer
and yeah so we can do equals one plus
two less than three so is this gonna say
is three less than three or is one plus
two less than three well the answer is
gonna do one plus two less than three
there's a notion of operator precedence
the Python documentation documentation
sells you what comes first which is
binds more tightly than others I'm not
gonna explain all that now you can look
it up or you can put parentheses around
stuff when it's not clear if it's not
clear to you good chance it won't be
clear other people so it it doesn't hurt
too much to put in extra parentheses it
makes you code a little bit unreadable
for a little bit less readable for
people who already know it and once you
get to know it so you should try to
learn some of them but don't worry about
learning all of them this is one things
I didn't tell you about but you can in
Python you can say is 1 less than 2 and
2 less than 3 all in one line all in one
expression which is kind of convenient
is 2 less than 1 and 1 less than 3 well
no because 2 is not less than 1 all the
boolean operators like and and or in
Python are short-circuit meaning it
won't
evaluate them all it will evaluate till
it knows the answers false and they'll
stop unless
keeps going three Darst are three means
3 raised to the 3rd power round one
point zero and one is going to round up
or down depending on if it's fifty one
person noticed that round of two point
five zero goes to two instead of three
that's because computers don't store
floating-point numbers the way we look
at them it's they store them with base
two using a I Triple E 754 I think great
54 is the standard that's the standard
that all computer hardware uses so it's
predictable what it's going to use but
it can't store arbitrary positions so
there are some rounding errors that will
happen that's one of the reasons why
people talk about dusty decks these
algorithms were written back when people
wrote using card decks and once the
experts math experts who do numerical
analysis figured out how to write that
algorithm so it doesn't drift one way or
the other with these little tiny
rounding errors then I don't want to
touch it because to get that provably
right is really hard so when you import
Python libraries especially from sight
by Euler you're occasionally importing
Fortran code for example stuff that's
been around a long time and is tested
and true it's easier to upgrade the
compilers for modern architectures than
it is to rewrite code cheaper easier
safer okay so
around that so here you notice that
here's an example where I have round
takes an argument well actually now I
can give it to so Python has this great
feature which is optional arguments
round you have to pass it at least one
argument but you can pass it a second
argument and in this case if you look at
the documentation for round it'll tell
you what that second argument does and
it basically says how many decimal
points after the decimal well what if
you put in a negative number you'd think
that might give you an error but someone
thought well yeah it's obviously an
error if you but there's a nice feature
we can add which is how far to move the
decimal point the other direction so you
can round that way as well
and there a bunch of sort of easter
english kind of features in python like
that where once you know there that I go
that's really handy okay
advanced exercises again all of the
exercises are start easy and get harder
so by the time you get the end of them
hopefully you're thinking really hard
and most of you won't get that far
here type callable help callable okay so
this tells you a little bit more about
what the callable function does you know
yeah all pretty straightforward here I
don't think there's much I want to talk
about because there's more interesting
stuff we'll keep going to oh here's
here's where I I said okay it with base
10 so what about that also base 10 but I
can do this so a second argument to int
is the base so see in base 16
hexadecimal is 12 in decimal any
questions
yep so the help callable he noticed that
the second argument was slash and so
that means no more required arguments
after that that's a fairly new feature
in Python there shows up with that slash
that's a documentation it's not actually
uh it's not the name of the second
argument because you can't happen at the
name of an argument if you name it you
can actually pass names I'll show you
that later has to be a valid identifier
anyway okay so strings there's a string
same string right so you can use single
quotes or double quotes whichever you
prefer
some people for double quotes because
they're more like see some people
further prefer single quotes because
there's like easier type and they are
pythons canonical representation you see
that you here we entered a string
literal when it shows us a string
literal it will use single quotes that's
when it can well what I mean when it can
well okay I want to put a single quote
in that string how do I do it I can't do
it that way because it gets to that
there defines a string and then sees
this s all by itself and then a dangling
unmatched single quote at the end so I
could either put a backslash in front of
it which escapes it's called escapes the
quote right so Python when it sees the
quote it says aw you're starting a
string and it remembers that and then it
starts adding characters to the string
so T is the first character the string
not the quote when it gets to a
backslash it says oh whatever comes next
I'm not going to do what I usually do
which in this case is end the string
instead I'm going to actually add that
character to the string and then it
keeps going when he gets to this one
which is not escaped with the backslash
it says okay that's the end of the
string because I was looking for I got a
quote and this is the second one
therefore it it is the two ends of the
string okay so you can do that notice
what Python does it gives it back to you
in the way it it's best effort at
representing the string it puts double
quotes around it in a single quote in
the middle which is a lot easier to read
so that's one of the reasons why you can
use double or single as it makes it
- right things with quotes inside them
like this like this how about two lines
no it doesn't work but that does so if
use triple quotes single apostrophe or
quote marks you can have multiple lines
newline characters in the strengths you
would enter and this is whether you're
in Python code or at the interactive
prompt in Python code if you're doing
inside a function and it's indented then
all those spaces that are indenting it
are gonna be part of the string okay
here I want to put triple quote around
triple quote so I want a single quote
there and a pair of double quotes there
it doesn't know what to do right so it's
got the four poets and row and it got
confused there's no that's cases where
theory the people who maintain Python
and or extend improving it could go make
that work but is it worth it there's
other ways to do it so it just gives you
an error and keeps that language faster
and easier to maintain being less code
this orchid here's the other way to put
new lines in of course wake up here we
put a new line in by hitting enter on
this base there that's because at the
interactive prompts it always puts in a
space as part of interacting with you
typing in is an operator in Python
operators aren't just pluses and minuses
and slashes their words sometimes to
like the in operator so is the string al
in the string hello so is it a substring
not in is also an operator those of you
who are familiar with other programming
languages you might find it funny that
this not isn't over here it's because
not in two words is a single operator
which means the opposite of in you can
also say not yell in hello it would work
but they're not and is easier to read
and there's lots of things in Python
that are done to make it easier to read
make it much more like you're reading
like you would be speaking
right so a string is stored in Python as
a sequence of characters a single
character in Python is stored as a
string of 1 right so there's not a
separate character and string type like
there is in some languages a character
is a string of length 1 a character the
string you can access elements of it so
here we use the square brackets to
access the element at index 0 so I would
say it which is going to be the H and we
get back a single character ie a string
of length 1 so it's the same type so
this single character string and this
multiple character string they're the
same type of type STR are those
characters stored as bytes or 2 bytes or
4 bytes
the answer is it's none of your business
you shouldn't have to care all right in
Python this string representation is an
abstraction of whatever was on the disk
or whatever came in over the network
it's an abstraction that's trying to
represent at a high level closer to
where we think about things it's a
string of characters right and if those
characters are Klingon or Korean or
French characters whatever it doesn't
matter Python knows how to handle those
when you put stuff on the disk then you
need to worry about it when you read
stuff off the disk you need to worry
about it and I'll show you some of that
later ok let's bind SNT to the same
object there they are I can look at them
so here you notice if I evaluate you've
seen this before just to remind her when
I say s comma T Python says oh you must
mean a tupple and so it interprets that
as a tupple and returns you a double
that's why it's putting the parentheses
around it it's handy for to be able to
do that though in several cases so this
is going to look at the llo and look at
the Jade create to string objects from
those literals concatenate them which is
allowed in Python when you use a plus on
string types it it puts them together
and return a new string object jello and
bind s to that
that uh what's T that's right
okay what's this gonna do
they're gonna change jello back to hell
strings are immutable that's right
strings and tuples are immutable in
certain to individual floats are in
beautiful that means they cannot be
changed and the way it shows up here is
string object does not support item
assignment so someone out there said it
answered the question correctly good for
being crane just keep answering
incorrectly
don't be afraid of answering the wrong
answer we're here to learn stuff yes
right so why why was it that before when
I had two lists m and two names and one
list I had a list object where I said M
equals n equals list and I then used M
sub square sub Braca
sorry M sub 0 M square bracket 0 equals
and I changed
that's because lists are mutable and the
equal in M square bracket 0 is a request
to list it for it to change itself in
this case I didn't use the in square
bracket so here it's actually this is a
request to Python to change the binding
of s to point to the object that gets
created by the right-hand side ok so yes
good good catch that those seem to be
behaving differently and they sort of
did and they sort of didn't so partly
it's because partly it's because the
list example earlier we had s we had M
sub 0 so I tried to do that here and I
can't so that's why that's why I had to
do it that way instead ok but I don't
like the fact that I have to go back so
I'm gonna make a note to fix that
okay
all right so s is still jello it didn't
change
hmm what's the beef
Oh in exercise the strings all someone
was working ahead
they were noticing the art for a quote
you're working a headed thing okay so
what's the B mean the B means bites so
in Python
there is a bites type which is really
great but it's actually a little bit
confusing and this is the first time I'm
trying the next treatment here so be
sure to write down notes if you can
think of ways to make it better but what
this does is the string type is an
abstraction of characters the bytes type
is bytes it's like one byte right but
you notice I didn't have to put in the
integer numbers that represent these
characters it assumed I meant ASCII and
it translated the H into the number for
me and the e is the number for me and if
I look at the type it so class is the
type back class bytes it's the type
bytes s1 is hello b1 is B hello are
these equal who thinks they're equal
raise your hand who thinks they're not
equal raise your hand
Oh Fairview they're afraid number you
know that they're not equal right so why
aren't they equal it's because by making
them not equal it helps you prevent it
helps prevent you from writing bugs so
character encoding was one of the things
that was well supported in Python too
but the way it was supported made it
confusing and it made errors like it did
the friendly thing which then you may
regret it later Python 3 you regret it
right up front it tells you right up
front no you can't do that so you can't
compare and that makes total sense right
if there are bytes on the disk I've got
a if I've got you know a byte which is
you know 220 followed by a byte which is
13 follow which a byte which is 7 and I
compare that to three characters well
they're not the same one is integers and
one is characters the fact that we use
integers are numbers to represent
characters that's the confusing part or
the part we have to make sure we think
carefully about the difference so what
if we want to take those bytes the
numbers that are in here
and turn them back into string
characters into characters in a string
this is how I do it I decode right so we
take characters we encode them in bytes
on a disk in a file or over the wire
like a network protocol so if I decode
them then I can compare it to the string
so if I take those that what looks like
a string was actually bytes and decoded
into a string then it actually is the
string hello and it's equal to the
string hello okay I keep going here what
if I take s1 and call encode on it
well s1 is a string when I call the
encode method it's going to return me an
encoded version of that string encoded
in bytes and it works now why did it
work partly because it encoded it with a
default encoding which is utf-8 and
utf-16
it's basically I'm going with that so as
long as you work with ASCII which is
seven bit then utf-8 is identical as
soon as you go past those first hundred
twenty seven characters then utf-8 you
start to get different numbers of bytes
per character sometimes and then how
many it depends on the character anyway
your turn to do some exercises in all
wonder
and one more comment so so I said that
the the way I'm doing the bytes and the
encoding and decoding I put a lot that
in the exercises so when you get about
half 10 the exercises I'll stop us and
go through it together I probably should
have moved some of that around
I saw
I think close to I think most more than
half of you have gotten about 1/3 away
through and I'm going to change the
structure here and I'm going to do the
second most of this is I'm not gonna let
you finish the exercise I'm gonna go
through them slowly and I I had planned
to shift that section around and forgot
to do it so to have more of it in the
lecture and less than the exercises so
let's look at this so if you put an R in
front of the string it doesn't do much
to that string it just seems like it's a
different way to do the same thing but
here look what happened
so our spam is spam our spam with the
backslash n it put a double backslash in
right and the R stands for R all I think
it seems kind of a funny name but
basically it means don't do any special
processing on the stream ie don't
interprets back slashes as an escape
character so when it sees a backslash it
puts it in and then it displays it to
you with a double backslash without the
R because this is what you would have to
type back in without the R to get the
same string as you type with the R and a
single backslash ok and and again the
exercise here was trying to get you to
figure that on your own and if you don't
that's fine it just helps you to work
your tiny gray cells as far I would say
the and you can see those those are the
same string right so if you put the no
no these are not right why are these not
the same because this one has a
backslash character and an end character
and this one has a newline character
which is what backslash n gets
interpreted as in a regular string and
you can see that the thinks is different
right so one's got one more string than
the other one one more character in it
than the other ok
yeah I'm gonna skip that one so you can
multiply strings which is basically
concatenate multiple copies of it you
saw you can catenate strings before but
you can't concatenate strings to other
things it's not those but you could turn
it into a string and then you can
catenate them okay well that's kind of
cool
if you have two string literals next to
each other Python assumes you want to
concatenate them so it'll do that as
part of parsing there's a dollar sign
there's a Unicode code point 24 looks
like a dollar sign there's a Unicode
name that camera exactly the right term
for that but unicode is the standard is
the standard we use for encoding
characters but the Unicode standard is
not so I have a pet peeve what is that
filing coded in well it's in card as
unicode no unicode is not in encoding
unicode is a standard that includes
things about encoding so so what ever
says to you it's a file encoded in
unicode yes say okay which one unicode
utf-8 utf-16 some other character
encoding so this is the there is a
there's a table table hundreds thousands
tens of thousands of think of characters
and they each have a name and this is
the unicode name for dollar sign and you
can use the backslash capital n it's
actually enter to that way if you want
and you can see that these are all the
same character hey interesting not
really helpful it happens to be that
those three are also stored in the same
object strings are immutable so I can do
that if it wants to but not every Python
implementation will do that okay just
think about equal so let's do a few
things with that dollar so if we encode
that looks like it's the same except the
B in front so when you encode it turns
it into a bytes object
and they are different as you saw
earlier with was it hello the string
hello and if you look at that you see
the types are different one string and
ones bytes it's a single byte long
let's encode it and take its first
element
I didn't say character on purpose
because it's not a character bytes don't
store characters they store bytes what's
first it's an int so that's interesting
if you take a bytes type like where was
it first so dollar encode you turn that
into bytes
well hello for example the bytes type
hello the bytes object hello
it looks like h-e-l-l-o it's not it's
actually whatever the number is it's a
it's a list of integers but it's sort of
intended to be used for encoding
characters right so it's kind of
interesting that when you take the bytes
type let me have a better example of
that second okay all right look if we
say
that's kind of weird isn't it so what's
weird is and this is the trick if your
noona player character encoding and you
think you I encourage you to just
remember that when you see a B it's
lying to you it's letting you into the
characters because it's convenient but
it's not storing them as characters it's
storing them as bytes and I'm just bytes
meaning lower level down on the disk
okay okay so if we look at the types of
these things we got you know string
bytes and int if we look at the dollar
string the encoded version and actus and
the first element of it if I take that
one over thirty-six and call the CHR
function on it it will give me back so
CHR and Ord let you map from ASCII
values to ask your characters I can turn
into binary a string representation of
it
alright let's take the pound sign do
something like that so there's the pound
sign character some of you might not be
able to display it that way it depends
on what version of Python what operating
system what shell so whether or not your
shell actually can display characters
beyond ASCII depends if I try to turn
that into a string oh yeah what would
turn you into a string B's isn't this a
string already the answer is yes it's a
string it's of type string if I do a
reprobate well repper all that's going
to do is show you what you would have to
tie is here's a string of five
characters the middle three characters
from the quote to the pound and the
quote that's what you would have to type
to get it back in if your interpreter
interactive prompt can let you type in
those characters I can turn that into an
ASCII and I get X a three using a
certain encoding okay okay let's look at
encoding a little bit more and then
we'll move on so in code we saw earlier
encoding utf-8 break is at what time I
think it's three
someone look it up for me please I think
it's three but yeah I'd like to know a
few minutes before thank you for that
reminder so if i encode the pound sign
using utf-8 it actually gives me two
characters sorry two bytes two values
right so if you take the pound sign and
coat it with utf-8 which is by far the
most popular encoding on the web has
been for almost a decade not quite you
get two characters or two bytes to
represent that oh sorry for being giving
all this detail about encoding you need
to know about it otherwise you get into
trouble and you'll just RRR
if you know what you get into then it's
not so bad what time's the break anyone
find out yet okay thanks so we think
it's three o'clock so utf-8 s-- the
default encoding I can pass it or just
give it no argument it'll assume that
it's two bytes long those are the values
of it right so you notice if I take that
and try to enumerate over I get the
integers out when I call a list it just
says whatever it is iterate over it and
give me the elements individually so
that's why I get two lists back with
those two and I can get the first one
the one 94 and look at as bytes and the
second one look at his bytes and here is
where you'll see in basically if these
if this is a 1 this is just for your
information if the first bit is a 1 then
it's the start of a multiple character
utf-8 character multiple byte
utf-8 character if it's a 0 it's not and
so in this case so with utf-8 when
basically running along you say all
these bytes that are less than 127 and
your 127 or less and you they all start
with a 0 as the highest bit most
significant bit and when so I'm reading
you to f8000 Lots just ask you ask
yes I get to one where oh it starts to
the one then I read the bite figure out
okay is this one you seem to be one more
character to more character or three
more characters
it reads those in and turns it into a
Unicode behind the scenes that store
something like that okay what else here
interesting so if I you encode that with
Windows 1252 which is it was the most
popular encoding on Windows I'm not sure
if it still is depends on how you
measure it it's a single character if i
encode it as iso-8859 - one which was a
popular HTML encoding it's the same as
windows 52 how about the Euro sign the
Euro sign in Windows 1252 is that byte
in utf-8 it's those three bytes in
iswait five 9s one it's not possible so
this is why if you're doing stuff you
sometimes need to worry about encodings
and how to do things always use you tip
8 always remember that characters are
encoded at a higher level abstraction
when you go to bytes or come back from
bytes you have to worry you have to know
what you're encoding from or to can't do
it that way I can use the ignore on the
encoding and it'll basically drop the
ones that can't convert or I can replace
them say replace then we'll replace the
characters a cant encode with a question
mark instead some interesting features
ok string functions and methods any
questions about all that encoding stuff
I think I that was the first time I
presented this material I think I've got
a lot change to make to make it a little
bit simpler a little bit easier more
feedback would be welcome yes
what was the first character it wasn't
it was two bytes what was the first byte
oh you could convert it and find out I
don't know what the actual number was I
let Python worry about that what's it
there you go
and and and you and you can't you
there's no one answer for it because
that first character changes that sorry
that first byte changes depending on
where in the Unicode code space in utf-8
it's trying to get to so encoded in that
first light I think you can have I'm not
utf-8 expert I think in that first bite
of a utf-8 more than one character
character representation like a two by
three byte or four byte utf-8 I'm pretty
sure that first bite actually some of
the lower order bits can change to I
could be wrong on that though okay yes
[Music]
bytes yeah okay it just it is confusing
here the here's the summary when pythons
running and you have it's doing things
with strings like you're saying is this
uppercase does this string end with an S
you're dealing with characters and the
characters are can be anything Hindi
Arabic Korean English English with an
accent imported from you know whatever
all sorts of stuff when you want to
store that on the disk you have to
choose and encoding to use you can't
just say well use the use the one that
everyone uses because everyone doesn't
use the same one there's some stuff
that's encoded as ASCII and only has 127
characters there's some stuff that's
coded as windows 1252 and has 256
characters I'm not quite there's some
stuff that's encoded as iso-8859 - 1 and
overlaps with Windows substitute - a lot
it's almost the same but there's some
that are different and then there's
stuff that neither of those can encode
at all like the Euro so you have to
choose an encoding the short answer is
always use utf-8 and you'll be happy as
long as it's supported all the way
downstream including the database how
many characters can be encoded in utf-8
was many it's 256 to the 4th power
almost plus right because I think for my
characters are the largest in utf-8 and
except for the first few bits any of
them can be used to encode that so
Unicode has tens of thousands I gets in
the 50,000 right here anymore
the difference between binary and writes
the bits I'm just saying I used the word
best to mean on the disk there's bits on
and off so it's actually the number
that's represented in binary the bytes
type is the way a convenient way to
store a list of integers in a compact
format that's almost always used to
convert between encoding z' between
encoding characters and unencoded
characters that's all it is and that's
why it looks funny when you look at it
it'll often show you characters even
though it's actually storing a list of
integers okay
string functions and methods I think so
the break is at 3 then I'll get through
at least some of this maybe all of it
and then you can either take your break
early or late or whatever choose when
you do work on the exercises we'll see
length for men what does it mean to take
the minimum of a string well men is
going to iterate over this object when
you iterate over a string you get four
strings each of length one and it's
going to show me the smallest character
in terms of the earliest in the in the
way it's encoded it's historically how
it was max works sorted always returns a
list does that string start with an S
does it start with an S and a P does it
end with an M give me an uppercase
version
give me a lowercase version take the
whitespace off the front in the back new
line tab space vertical form feed all
those things just rip them off actually
no just take them off the right side
no and I'll actually just take them off
the left side okay take off now this
one's confusing you might think this is
dropping the CSV the dot CSV from the
end of a string but it's not this is
actually dropping the dot or C or an S
or a V from the right side which doesn't
look any different there but here
it does a and here it certainly does
right so this one's a gotcha that some
people get confused about so our strip
and strip and L strip take a a string
and it looks for any character in that
string and rips it out okay split is a
method on string that returns a list of
strings split on any white space by
default if you give it an argument then
it's not going to take the default of
any white space it's going to use
exactly what you give it so here it's
gonna look for the two character string
comma space comma space and there it's
the end of string so it doesn't matter
whoa look at all those methods I did a
Durer of str or maybe a dur of the
string what i do a during the class
itself or the type of self there's lots
of methods on there let's just look at
what they are well that's a little bit
easier to read but there's lots of them
if I look at the string or the type
they're the same which is mildly
interesting for those of you who know
what's going on behind the scenes a
little bit more experience index says
please find that string in the larger
string so look for that string PA in the
string spam and it finds it at character
offset one zero one so there's the one
in two or this is index is just like oh
no index will raise a value error if it
can't find what you're looking for find
is just like index except it has
different behavior when you when it
can't by the string
these are all fairly straightforward oh
I can replace the e with a three all
ease with three or just one e with three
and that's it
so start the break now come back at
about 3:15 3:18 you can work on the
exercise now or later if you want to
break snack coffee before I want to go
up now instead of later shorter lines
spread it out
okay welcome back from the break some of
you had time to work through some of the
exercises I'll go through them now and
show you what you missed or the ones you
didn't get to before I do that had some
couple comments helpful comments on the
utf-8 encoding those pieces and a blog
post was at Jolan software very good old
blog post on understanding encoding
there's a bunch of good ones out there
that explain encoding again it's it's I
don't know if you need to know the depth
I put in here I'll probably simplify for
next time but understand at least about
encoding the two levels of structure you
can't mix them easily and when you do
you have to be explicit on what you want
to do so if someone gives you a file and
you just open it and read it
without asking them what encoding is
that file then someone's made a mistake
like you need to know what encoding a
file is if you want to safely get the
characters out of it and similarly for
like a a stream of data it's usually not
as important to ask because it's usually
encoded in the headers between like the
browser and a server it's already that
negotiation happened for you but if it's
just a file on a thumb drive or email to
you find out what the encoding is okay
so exercises here so sorted spam and
let's think about what's this going to
do well sort it is a function that takes
any iterable string is a kind of
interval a list is kind of interval a
couple's interval addicted interval
there's lots of other file handle and
then it pulls out all those elements
which for a string are going to be the
individual characters representative
strings and puts them in in sorted order
little sidebar there you can pass an
optional character optional argument
reversible truth puts me in the reverse
order reversed is a built-in function
that takes an interval and returns a
reverse object at a particular address
so many over time Python has is gent is
is slowly and steadily marching towards
more and more lazy evaluation so don't
evaluate until you have two generators
do this a lot of functions do this the
views on dictionaries etc so in this
case the reversed object won't give you
them in reversed order until you ask for
them individually and that's in many
cases can be more efficient because it's
not putting stuff into memory you might
never want anyway well in this case it's
all memory anyway but if you want to
iterate some over something to see
what's actually in it like a reversed
iterator you want to do the iteration
the easy way is just pass it off to the
list built in it will iterate over it
for you and return the list okay upper
is upper title is title see the pattern
there there's a bunch of them there or
the is is the predicate function or
predicate method it's called because the
answer is yes no question and title
returns a title case version of the
string
and you can see what title case does
with spaces swap case right so here
we've done what's called method chaining
we called a method so this object this
method was called on it a new string
object was returned which was spam eggs
in uppercase and then the swap case
method was was called on that object to
swap the case so method chaining is
becoming more popular especially in some
libraries in Python is that string
substring is PA a substring of the spam
string is the exclamation point in that
string
willy nilly find ill it said index one
right there find the first one that
starts after six that should be that one
there we go
offset seven anyone get through far
enough like it's not gonna work for me
because I didn't define s anyone figure
out what s dot index zero s index space
does oh so when yours s was defined
thank you that's helpful
where's mine it was not because I had
reset my interpreter right so if we set
s to hello world as an example which I
think I did next and then go back and do
it well then we see I mean basically
what's going on here is that s dot index
says look for the O but starting at the
character starting at this character
position where this character position
is whatever s dot index spaces return so
it's gonna start looking at space for to
find the hole so it's going to get the O
there okay yeah then you can see ya
build it up to see okay count the spaces
in string how do I check for more spaces
of non spaces in a string think about us
all that
you know that they say about regular
expressions if you have a problem that
you solved with regular expressions now
you have two problems this because
they're so it like for simple stuff
they're great you soon you just it's so
easy to go over this line that's hard to
see it's in it's visible line and
suddenly like why did I write
reconstruct so yeah they're great but
keep them small Mergen expression would
work you could do an S count with spaces
you could do a replace with spaces and
count what's left there's a bunch of
ways to do it I'm not gonna actually go
through yeah that was a question okay
questions before you move on so let me
go check how many of you think I've been
going too fast raise your hand how many
of you think I've been going too slow
raise your hand so at least within the
bounds of people's courage to stick
their hand up alone I'm hitting the
right stride good and other feedback is
welcome in the there's a little comment
box in the survey I think you could type
as much as you want I'd like to hear it
I was tightening with someone over lunch
who said yeah these you know surveys are
a great way to get feedback but
sometimes it's kind of you know it's
kind of passionate not very polite
feedback if you're so frustrated that
you can only give me feedback online
impolitely I'd still like to hear that
because that's really important feedback
from you and I have in teaching over the
years sometimes gone too far on the
frustrate users to help them think make
them think I've gone I've gone across
that line sometimes so feel free to tell
me I'd like to know so print and string
formatting no difference when you're in
the repple in script or code you're
running if you just put a three it's
never gonna print out you have to
actually call the print function all
right
I can call it with multiple arguments by
default it separates the arguments with
a space
here you can see print three four it
printed and then there's a new line that
got printed just like the repple printed
a new line after it so by default
there's a new excuse me new line you can
put a backslash n to add another one you
can do this in Python 3
most people are moving towards a dot
format operator or F strings so the way
this works and you still see it it's
it's basically this percent that I
showed you earlier as a mod operator
like a remainder is saying is basically
saying please look in this string for %
D and interpolate is the official term
for that number into that string so you
get three good reasons however this is
much more common in newer versions of
Python since two six or two seven I
think and so what happens here is it
looks for curly braces and then matches
the argument to the curly brace that's
in the string okay so there's the format
built-in method you can call it with no
arguments and there's nothing to
interpolate not a problem you can call
it with an argument that doesn't get
interpolated because this string didn't
have it but if you say I want to
interpolate something and there isn't an
argument to interpolate then it tells
you there's a problem and there are good
use cases for why it would allow these
other ones because you don't I mean here
we're playing with toy strings where we
know the string we know the argument
ahead of time often in your program you
have multiple cases and some runs or one
sometimes through the loop you might
have a values there other times you
wouldn't and you could simplify Co it by
having these at least in some cases more
relaxed interpretation such as this one
where you have an argument but know
where to put it yeah that's no different
so high class I can use numbered
arguments if I want used to have to use
now you they're optional and that's
advantageous if you want to change the
order which again in this toy example
it's more confusing than helpful but in
real world examples it would sometimes
be more helpful than confusing you can
also repeat them that way
so they're a good
good uses cases good times it's good to
have the ability to use numbered
arguments and then you can see like the
: d here not again
reminder I'm not expecting you to
memorize all this stuff just let it wash
over you and absorb as much as you can
ok so he so you're aware of all the
things you can do just like strings
there's tons of things you can do a
string I would say I think this is good
advice if when you're trying to figure
how to do something in Python and you
know oh yeah I could do that with an
index and of this Andalou think is this
something that lots of people have done
before and wanted to do before and if
the answer is yes there's probably
already a way to do it that doesn't
involve you writing five lines of code
there's probably a method or a built-in
function and if Stack Overflow doesn't
give it to you just keep looking because
it's almost always there standard
libraries same thing the standard
library and python is huge people say
it's batteries included and for probably
the first six seven years of me
programming quarter my time a Python I
kept kind of every few months like oh
that's in a standard library why did I
write the write that code six months ago
because it's just lots of stuff hiding
in there that you know I and I'm the
type that reads manuals up front like
let's just read to the standard library
manual these skim it to see what's there
then I'd forget stuff okay back to
string formats so : D is the way so you
put a colon after the missing argument
here so so again here the the argument
is just the implied first one because
it's the first string here and then : D
is a modifier that says here's how I
want you to format that argument so I
want to format it as a decimal number or
a number ten characters why right
justified or same thing but put the
negative all the way at the left side or
explicitly right justify put underscores
in front of it left slide to the left of
it put it in the centre lots of stuff
what's it yeah you can do that too
and I have some duplicates here
I don't what that one does equal plus 5t
what's the five it's only showing Kyle I
think it says no no oh so yeah I can't
remember there's actually a good online
resource called pi pi format I think dot
enforcement like that that just shows
you lots and lots of examples it's a
really complicated like there's lots of
features and I don't know nearly all of
them you can also put names in like this
and then give argument names like that
to match them right so and in most
recent versions of Python you can use an
F string where it will look in the
current namespace for greet and who so
if I have these names in the current
namespace when the string executes then
it will find them they put them in and
that's these F strings are like way
almost always far more readable than the
dot format version because you can see
the placeholder okay your turn to spend
if you miss a sense exercises
okay I'm gonna move us along here and
I'll go through these exercises so you
notice you can take that print takes D
for optional arguments like what to
separate what to use is the separator
between its argument its other arguments
other than space or what's use a ending
string instead of the newline character
if you want to have nothing as the end
character you might think that n equal
and then give it an empty string would
work but it won't sorry that end equals
none would work but it won't you have to
give it an empty string and that's
because the end equal none that's the
way almost all functions when they're
written they take they say well this is
a character that you you you have to you
can supply what you want to end with or
if you give us nothing then we'll use a
newline I'm sending end equals none is
like not giving it there's no way for
the called function to actually tell if
you explicitly called it with none or
just left the argument off so that's a
little gotcha that shows up in other
places as well once you realize that's
the way functions are implemented you
won't it won't trip you up as much
nothing new there there we duplicated
switch around alright so here you can
see that seven is the width and point
two is how many decimal places and those
mean different things for different
items like the s if you say it's a
string then the dot means how whether or
not to truncate and how closely or held
tight B is binary Clairol hex
hexadecimal octal %
so it does the bath for you and puts in
the % here it's print for me one three
five wide two after the decimal point
and it's a present so here notice that
we have a curly braces pair and inside
it there's a curly brace pair exactly
where you would expect to see how many
digits after and so there you can
see how that works obviously if you know
upfront what they are stick them in the
string but if this is a variable that
changes with various runs or
configuration or whatever that's when it
makes sense to use it and you can even
do something like that where take time
objects the date/time object has its own
format specification so when format
method runs it actually the objects it
actually goes and talks to the object to
say what do you have add under format
method and if so it uses it to figure
out how to do it so you can write your
own in theory syste version info is an
example of a named tupple in python so
it's it's like a list it's like a couple
of elements that you can access by index
or by name and so for example here I can
say Pass sis as the argument and then I
put dot version info as the part of that
argument I want so yes so then it's
gonna show me sis top version info or I
can pass in this case they use the
format in this case I'm using the up
string so it's gonna look for a sister
info and just take oh it's gonna put the
whole thing same thing in there
I think that's a little confusing make a
note and notice in in the F strings you
can put inside these curly braces I mean
here I've got you know take that piece
out and multiply it by three and add
five it'll play if you put almost any
Python expression in here which is not
true for the dot format method the dot
format method there's not quite as much
Python you could play there so a few
restrictions but not too many so and
that can wait I mean like in my opinion
that's starting to get pretty ugly and
hard to read so when do you put stuff
inside the curly braces when you put it
in the format whatever is gonna be
readable easiest to read by yourself or
someone else six months ago is the way
answering a similar question think about
readability okay questions on format
printing okay tuples and lists there's a
list there's a tupple you can pass any
iterable to a list you know create one
for you you can pass you can access and
you can ask a list to change its element
at index one so it's going to instead of
referring to the B it's convert or to
its to refer to the B so it can change
itself they are immutable
I could take any iterable and pass it to
the tupple built-in name that callable
and it will create a couple from it and
if i try to change the contents of a
tuple though i'm gonna get an error does
not support I don't know Simon but you
create them mixed of course there's no
restriction that tuples all be the same
type the only place you start you see
that all the things in a data structure
need to be the same type or things like
all string they all have to be strings
and then you see in other libraries like
numpy where columns have to be all the
same type if you want to be fast okay so
can I concatenate lists the answer is
yes and you see what happened I got a
new list those two lists stuck together
sort of
of course the original list didn't
change I didn't use plus equal here I
just use plus right earlier I used two
plus two equal size please modify the
list extend it can I so here I added a
list - a list here I'm adding a couple
to int and it says you can only
concatenate a couple to topple okay so
let's try counting it up at the top hole
read the error what happened so right
here not int it's seeing an int there
why well because round brackets in
Python are used both to create tuples to
call functions and to enforce precedents
and mathematical expressions or make
them more readable or both so the four
is being interpreted as not a tuple with
a single element but as the number four
well there's a that works okay that
worked for creating a couple no it
didn't you're gonna add so T equal or
that actually said T is now an int so
that's not working and it doesn't matter
how many parentheses you put on it's not
going to help but you can see how it
here here if I put ABC is even giving me
a couple here and then tupple four and
it gave me an int here I give template
ABC it gives me a couple of three
characters so if it can iterate over
what you pass it it will do so and put
those elements in the list in the tuples
sorry if you need to create a tuple with
a single element you can do it that way
and you can see that it works so
occasionally I'll see that on that but
as well like here and that's what's
going on there so it's sort of this
collision between the multiple uses of
parentheses we have this edge case that
we have to handle so a comma trailing is
allowed is required and in fact like
trailing comma is allowed in lists and
tuples and dictionaries and that's quite
handy when you have a list or and you
split across multiple lines you'll often
see a comma after between them you'll
have element cumber one comma element 2
comma and the last element comma and
then the closing square bracket and that
people once you get used to it's more
readable it's easier to edit
much reasons why people do it that way
oops got an area typo here
let's do that and that was that line 433
but the second typo is that two dollars
no okay so now if I take the tupple T
which is ABC I can add the temple 4 and
I get ABC 4 as a new table right so you
can do the math as you concatenate
multiple versions of itself there's
another way to create an empty tupple
Hay List B CDF like for minimum maximum
sorted burst
mr. burst I think you've seen all this
and the exercises before why is this if
you like repetition they could have
another error is that eight dollars you
know four dollars now there you go just
reinforce me thank you so m dot insert
0a what that does is is going to insert
a into the list em before index zero
what's that going to do
someone said at the end so let me read
this one again insert a before index 0
so what's insert e before index minus 1
what is index minus 1 on a list that's
index minus 1 so if I insert e before
the index of I'm gonna get it before
yeah okay so if you someone asked me
earlier about how do you read slices and
where's it gonna put it well if you
think I always think of before in cases
where it's I think in most cases maybe
all cases where it's ambiguous think
about it as before the index you're
giving is you wanted to put it in before
that put it in before that and then it
makes sense and we'll see some other
examples that later M don't remove e
this is one that sometimes people get
confused and think it's going to if you
pass in a number it's gonna remove an
index it's not it's gonna look for that
element so M remove looks through the
list finding one that's equal to E and
removes it from the list
now you notice it didn't return anything
so it doesn't pull it out a list and
give it a copy it just asks the list to
remove that element from the list
well actually what I couldn't remember
also m dot pop will pop the last item
and return it
and what I couldn't remember earlier but
I'm sure I'm remembering right but
someone feel free to prove me wrong is
that if you had to ease analyst it finds
the first one who removes it doesn't go
looking through the whole list it says
just remove the first stone
that matches that that is equal to that
all right so pop does return element and
remove the last one
so let's bind I to the 1 + j2 - okay so
I don't need the parentheses here I'm
doing this is sometimes called Tuffle
assignment or unpacking basically if the
right side is an iterable and the left
side is multiple names like a implied
temple that can be it over it'll do
multiple name assignments at the same
time sorry about that
alright so there's a couple of three
there's another couple of three are they
equal what does it mean for two tuples
to be equal the answer is its that they
have this they have the same contents
meaning that each of their elements are
equal so when you say are two lists
equal or two strings equal are two
tuples equal Python those two are
looking at each element and if it gets
to the end and they were all equal then
the tupple is considered to be equal the
two tuples are considered to be how many
threes are in there you saw this before
with strings
all right so much the same this looks
kind of weird but it's really nice left
side right side is for elements left
side is three but the star says put
extras in there so what's gonna happen
is n 3 will be 3 and 4 will be 4 and
rest will be all the rest of them it
doesn't remember the type on the light
side like this is a list over here it's
just looking at this as an interval
iterates over it doesn't know that it's
a list it just puts them all into a list
it turns out alright so n 3 was assigned
3 & 4 for wrestlers design 4 5 6 and
then because I used commas between them
here it shows it to me as a double it's
actually it's doing
three named assignments is the part that
matters if I put in the middle here
works cool you can't it can't be
ambiguous so it doesn't always
it doesn't read your mind so your turn
now to do exercises for tuples noises
okay
let's get I'm gonna stop those of you
haven't quite finished and go through it
it's a group here there's no one that
exercise is pretty long so lists okay so
you can see here that if you're gonna
use the plus equal operator on a list
the object has to be an interval such as
another list also implies it doesn't
have to be another list it couldn't be
any iterable sure enough append appends
an element to a list and append appends
an element to a list takes only one
argument
okay so let's append an element to a
list and we have a list that contains as
its last element a list of three strings
okay let's delete that one
so before you saw him remove here I'm
saying do Adele of M minus one this is
not a namespace operation it's a request
to the list object that M is bound to to
remove its last element so this last
element is the list efg so i remove that
and now it stops at D and if I use
extend instead and give it an iterable
like a list then I get the FG added each
of those okay
that comment I forgot to take out I
think yes ma'am
yep 5:00 a.m. right so similar
alright so in here just like in you know
in a string here it's just looking to
see if it's in there and you can see
that in and not in not in as a single
operator or not the expression of with
the in operator either works well how
about that one five six I see five six
in that list I know I don't do it but
now I do
so is that object in that object so that
list now contains five six before it
contain five and it can say six but as
in as separate objects that's
interesting
M is one two three four five six seven
all the way up to G with some weird mix
of integers and strings n is three
characters one two and four three
elements and one two and four so Python
lets me compare those two objects and it
will go through them and say is 1 less
than 1 yes is sorry M less than n
there's one less than 1 yes
two less than 2 yes three less than four
yes and then it runs off the end of this
list and it's done so it says sure true
so you're allowed to compare lists of
unequal length and any intervals other
intervals of unequal length that's not a
problem
doing lots of it I'm packing on the
right to decide to have to bind multiple
names here multiple assignments do you
know if any iterable works on the right
side as long as it's the right length
all these are unsurprising there's a
split like we saw before gives us a list
join is the reverse so if you call split
on a string it returns a list if you
call join on a string it returns and
pass it a list if you pass a list to
join on string it returns a string sure
this one line 520 where this line i ji k
IJ k l m n o p so this did the
assignment this is showing the values
he's right there
hi j/k breasts is l m n o p i think it
is
nobody else in the problem
yep yep so what happens here is Python
looks at this interval 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
objects and it looks the left side 1 2 3
4 5 6 and says okay I can do the last
two and the first 3 and all the extras I
will stick into there yep you're the
only one that asks some of the other
people were thinking they were probably
oops so here I join on space I can join
on something like a comma space I can
join an empty string just to concatenate
strings together you'll often see that
as a pattern because joining concatenate
two strings one at a time is slow if
you're doing big strings appears a lot
faster now it doesn't usually matter
occasionally does okay there's this m
dot sort called the sort method on the
list m and it will sort in place and it
doesn't return anything or more
precisely it returns none none object
reverse similar okay let's start over
again I could do sort ask it to sort
itself in reverse order and that works
too I can ask it to sort itself and
reverse itself why will this fail
so remember how it meant that chaining
works is that this will create a list
that looks the same as that one
this will ask that list to sort put
itself into sorted order and it will
return nothing
and then Python will try to look up the
name reverse on the nun object and it
can't find it so I'm gonna get a name
error or an attribute error on the nun
type object the nun object which is of
type of gun type sorry no no some it
depends so some methods don't return
anything some do so in this case sort in
reverse I have a specific reason they
there is a specific reason for that I
don't like it but but it's it's because
there are built-in functions sorted and
reversed and built and methods on list
sort and reverse without the D on the
end and by not by returning none it
makes it even more clear that continue
if you use the wall around by mistake
so we could say m equal list m dot sort
m dot reverse that would work fine
well sort returns none yep and here's
the sorted function well it's not though
I called it as a method there's no
sorted method there is a sorted function
okay so sort and reverse our methods on
lists or and possibly other objects
sorted is a built-in function that takes
any iterable and returns a list of those
elements in sorted order okay any
questions
all right let's do some stuff with nice
sequencing yes does what so the method
reverse is a request to the list to
reverse its contents and it returns none
it's a request to the list to reverse
itself and the list method does do that
in theory you can write your own reverse
on some other object it doesn't it but
reversed is a function that takes any
iterable and returns a list hey remember
that exact difference it's okay if you
forget that but in general you got to
remember these little details that's
part of what keeps you happy when you're
programming okay so there's a list
access element zero number three
the last element second-to-last element
okay so what's this one gonna do this is
going to return this one returns an
element an element at Noella this one is
a slice and it returns a sub list and
the sub list is going to be a list of
elements that start at index zero and
stop before they get to index one so
what will this return some people said
March and that's not quite right it's
going to return a list of all the
elements starting at zero and ending
before one so it's not gonna return
March it's going to return March right
it's gonna return a sub list okay and
that's a tricky thing
this one will start at zero and stop
before two so it will return March and
April in a list that's nice this one
will return the whole list start at zero
stop before you get to the minus one
element it will return the whole list
except for July okay this one will start
at zero and stop before it gets to
element 100 who thinks it'll give an
error raise your hand who thinks it'll
give the whole list raise your hand
yeah it'll actually work so it's
completely reasonable to think it might
give you an error many languages would
in Python it's like well if again as
long as you think the reason I'm using
this stop before you get to is that way
of thinking about it makes it at least a
little bit more comfortable that this
would not return air okay it's a
language choice when they design it that
this works and that actually does come
in handy sometimes this returns a list
starting as early as you can and
stopping as late as you can because
we've left off the start and stop so it
returns the whole thing and those are
three ways to do the same thing okay so
all three of those basically make a new
list all of these are making a lude list
this is a new list new list new list new
list
and these in this case all three times
they're months to was bound to a new
list where the elements and their order
was the same as the oldest but it's a
copy of the list okay so the difference
is the list stores the ordering of the
objects the objects are shared between
them but those are all the immutable
objects their strengths so you can
safely change one and the others won't
be changed okay there's a couple there's
a copy of the tupple oh no that's not I
think I just learned something earlier
check
no no I am right okay yeah so if you use
so so all of these using start with that
temple if you use square bracket it
returns a sub a slice of the temple and
it is a temple type because it's a
request to that object so it returns the
same type and you can do it but you
can't do coffee there's no coffee
attribute you can't there's no coffee
method on top of but there's almost some
objects haven't copy some don't in
general when you are writing is to
remind me to tell you this in general
when you're writing a function try not
to think okay I'm gonna get an argument
which is a list and I need to do some
things with this list instead think more
generally if you can instead write the
function as okay I've got this list now
I want to do something with it let me
write a function but let me write the
function so that takes any iterable and
works on it and don't assume that it's a
list assume that it could be a list or a
temple or a string or an open file
handle or open network handle or
anything that can be iterated over a
generator a January expression then your
code will be more reusable you'll find
you're using it for things you didn't
intend it for down the road which is
really nice okay let's get back to that
list
there's months two which is a copy they
are the same they are the same what
they're equal those two lists are equal
when you compare them they are equal are
they the same two names for the same
list no because remember I create a new
list when I used the square brackets so
there are different list objects that
happen to share the same contents if I
ask months zero to delete it zeroth
element the element the beginning March
it will do so and we can see that March
got dropped but months two which is a
different list March is still there
if I take months which was April May
June July at months I'd concatenate
these two lists together and rebind
months then I get more April May June
July so it just it created a new list
which was same as this list plus one in
front of it as a new list I said okay
can I do this again I was just gonna say
doesn't support item assignment no I can
do this because it's a list lists are
mutable there we go so we fixed March I
can append an element to list I can
change that element like this meaning I
can add a new object as the last element
in the list in place of the object that
was there right I didn't change the
string lowercase August to be a
different string like they're still
there was a string lowercase August and
it got thrown away and I put a new one
in this place Dell months two is gonna
return what I was going to do what to
list the list will then be March April
June July August
hey what's this it's a list of lists we
saw a hint of that when we had the five
six seven I think in there so it's a
list with two elements each of which is
a list of three elements and if I access
the zeroth list I get the list ABC the
list 1 2 3 if I access this list and
then access is the zeroth element I get
the 1 back okay so you can use lists of
lists to do a 2-dimensional or multiple
array of course if you're doing anything
that's big or you want to be fast you
would use numpy or append is there
something like that instead but
occasionally you would do that and any
questions before you take your turn at
the exercises okay
you
you
you
okay I'm gonna continue here the first
part this exercise is the as the most
interesting stuff I think alright so
remember what so we have a list 0 1 to M
sub 1 equals is there is we're basically
asking the list to change this link or
the the piece in here that refers to the
object 1 and change it to instead refer
to that at 10 20 so this 10 20 a list 10
20 is gonna replace the one I hope I did
okay that hopefully makes sense let's
put it back to 0 1 2 and now what we're
saying is let's replace what well this
is saying so if you if you just pull
this out if we just access this we're
gonna get the sub list that starts at
element or index 1 starts at X 1 and
stops before it gets to index 2 well the
element that the part of the list which
stops starts at index 1 and stops before
index 2 is just the single element in
there and here we're saying replace that
sub list with instead this sub list 10
20 so we actually take the 10 and 20 and
stick them in as two new elements in
that list okay and one person was asking
why wouldn't it be something else which
this is the way that Python interpreter
just gotta get used to that there's not
really a wrong or white way to think
about it Python shows one way and so
hopefully the way I've been describing
this start and stop before will help you
at least get get the balance right which
is the most important part
what's it it's it's that's right here
it's saying change that element to that
sub list here it's saying please change
that sub list to a different sub list
that's right
this is not like could be unpacking
earlier and in fact it couldn't be and
this this example shows you it's not
because it's sing it's a sub list of one
element and we're replacing with a sub
list of two elements so if you replaced
it with a sub list of a thousand
elements it would just slide them all
over and stick those elements in I
supposed to stick me in one object I'll
skip that and these ranges I'm not going
to cover but basically the same thing
you can do with slices which are what
these actually objects that get created
us with that syntax are and range have
very similar syntax and you can play
around with those they're kind of
complicated make you think hard
maybe you some unexpected things but you
can see you basically we're saying okay
range 101 for example we're saying start
by default at zero and go cuz range you
could have multiple arguments as well
which I don't show you here what doesn't
do right there right so start at zero
stop before you get to 101 and create a
list from and that that will that's a
range object and then you can access
elements of the range objects saying
start at the last item item and then
count by minus ten to get there as
intent index over and stop before you
get to element at index one that
language almost no I think always saying
it that way always will give you the
right answer
this argument no one
so the first the slice has three up to
three numbers and always a colon so the
number before says start at start with
the element at that index the second one
says stop before you get to the element
at that index and the last says instead
of increasing by one increase or in this
case decrease by a different amount yep
the step exactly
okay so range is an object that you can
iterate over to go from zero up to seven
inclusive stop before you date this is a
list comprehension it has square
brackets same syntax as a list but
inside it's not individual elements it's
sort of like a for loop which we haven't
seen yet in this tutorial and basically
you get to choose the name E and then
there's a for a set of names here in and
then an expression that gets evaluated
so E for e'en ranged eight what's just
going to give you gonna iterate over
that whole range and give you a list of
those elements you can do this with a
for loop it's a little bit longer the
big advantage to list comprehensions is
they are they are a declaration of what
you want as opposed to a declaration of
how to make what you want right so it's
a slightly higher level of abstractions
I want to have a list that's that that's
more like a mathematical expression
saying this is what I want you know you
know if you did create with the loop
you'd have to create a for loop and say
well I want you to loop over and add
these things well then you're telling it
how to do it you can put any expression
on the left here so you - sorry I said
you choose that name that's not true you
choose this name this is the name that
you control the second one so e4e in
range it's just after the four is where
you choose whatever name you want or
multiple names if you're a Turing over
something that can
dude mm I'm packing or unpacking so here
I'm going to take each of those 0
through 7 inclusive and multiply by 2
and I should get back the list 0 2 4 up
to 14 okay
or I can add I can also add an if clause
afterwards if and then after the F comes
any expression could be quite a long
complicated one
so only gave me the even ones and the
expression doesn't have to be I mean
it's it's any arbitrary expression so
here the expression is an F string all
the way to the end of that quote so it's
gonna return me that string evaluated
eight times with each time through the e
being 0 then 1 then 2 all the way up to
7 so I should get back a list of 8
strings that are like that and you can
buy them too you can find a member if
you alright so here's the long
expression for that if that and we get
some of it
so I said like we look back here that's
pretty easy to read this one not so much
if I saw that encode you were asking me
to review I'd say just make a for loop
with teacherís
and that's my general advice is use list
comprehension sparingly make sure they
have no side effects like don't put
print statements inside or something
like that and usually avoid nested ones
you can actually nest you can have a
list comprehension says e or e in this
for exit you could have them
nested multiple times but they get
pretty hard to read after a while
question
for the last one this one I would say 4e
in range 8 : well first I would have to
create a list create an empty list
before the for-loop create the for loop
and then for each element in the for
loop if e % 2 equals 0 if it's an even
number then I would append this element
to the for them but to the list what is
what is so this is an F string F quote
quote that's an F string which means
it's an expression like a format string
that's in that is evaluated and it looks
for the e in the current namespace which
we created by say naming it by using the
name in the for yeah yep great questions
so here here's the name that's going to
have each time through a different value
I don't use it all in the expression
right it's all kind of silly I don't
think I would use that easier ways to do
that but I'm just pointing out here's
here's exactly how what's going on help
you understand it hopefully here's the
months in alphabetical order
a comes before F comes before M okay
these are months these are tuples which
include a month a month number and a
number of days non-leap years okay
like all sorted on them it returns me a
sorted list which is the same one
because remember when you compare tuples
it compares April to a February and then
it compares for two then a comparison
thirty twenty will never got that far
because the a and the F and the F and
the M it made the comparison right there
and stop right there and figure out what
to order put them in I can reverse the
sorted okay element to is gonna give me
the tupple marks 331 so here's a
function we haven't seen a function yet
in this tutorial but I think most of you
probably see them before all right but
the way it works is that the def starts
a block you give the name of the
function you give any arguments you want
and then you have the body of the
function which is all the indented stuff
possibly index it further and then it
ends with the first non indented line or
when you're in the repple like we are
the read eval print loop you have to
have a blank line so this blank line is
optional in code you're writing in a
file it's required in the repple because
otherwise it doesn't know what you
whether you're done or not right so get
index is just gonna return whatever you
pass it element number 1 so if I call
index
I don't like that name so this will
return February to 28 right 0 1 2 just
asking for one so get it next one is
going to return element index 1 of
months up to a month sub 2 is marks 331
index element 1 is going to be 3 right I
realize I just made a note to myself
month is a bad name here because it's
anything does not be a month let's
import the operator module and use its
item getter operator item getter built
in I sorry the function in there
so if item Gator is a function that you
pass it an argument and it returns a
function over here finds that kind of
hard to think about a function that
returns a function come on come on be
honest yeah it is hard to think about
when I started using Python that was one
of the things that for me was hard to
think about it took me a while to used
to it and decorators were like because
they're functions that return functions
or calls that return functions so most
of them are well yes most of them are
unless it's decorating a class that's a
functions class anyway the point is this
is kind of hard to think about but it's
just a simple way to write a function
right like this is one way to write a
function that returns whatever you pass
it it accesses index element one and
returns that part of it this is another
way to create the same function object
no an equivalent function object right
and the way I give it a name here is I
do a def get index the way I give it a
name here is I just say equal well
whatever that thing is whatever that
object is that gets returned which I
know is a function object because that's
the documentation to item Peter says
give it the name and getting next one
and then it just works the same way ok
this is a common thing you'll see in
Python
his functions returning functions
functions that take functions as
callbacks have you seen that before
Python give me example no no sorry I
that was a trick question and it was the
trick was on me sorted is one but we've
seen sorted only with reverse equal true
which is not a function you can call
sort with a key function and a comp
function so that's actually sort and
sorted or another one that can take a
callback function so sorry about that
check on me so if I call get index one
of months sub one I'm gonna get two
right there's months of one that object
I passed it to get an X one it's gonna
return me index one of that object there
we go good so do I need to give it a
name in order to call it no I can just
take that and stick it right in place of
that so I take so so again it's kind of
complicated what's going on here is
Python looks up this module name which
was imported so it's in my name space it
accesses the object that's got the name
item getter which is a function I call
it with the integer object one it
returns to me a function and I call that
function passing it that thing and it
gives me back something ok so that works
just as well so there was a
foreshadowing to what I was trying to
get you to say here is a function sorted
that takes a function as an argument and
what it does is this is one of the ways
one of there are several ways in Python
to take some existing code which either
was by design or by accident somebody
wants to let me rephrase that sorted was
designed so that you could change its
behavior without having to go in and
change the sorted module or the sorted
function in a module in Python you'll
have to go edit the sorted function you
can just change its behavior by giving
it a key function so what sort does is
it takes the two things coming in and I
don't exactly what it does but you know
I'd say oh how long are they ok well let
me start marching through them let me
compare the first two and see which ones
smaller but it actually doesn't do that
what it does is it says
okay let me compare the first two to see
which one's smaller but only if they
didn't pass me a key function if they
passed me a key function then I'm gonna
take those two objects call the key
function on both of them and get
something else back and I'm gonna pair
I'm going to compare those two objects
to see which one is smaller okay that's
what's going on here so if and then so
what what sorting is going to do with
this key callback function is this gonna
call this function on those objects like
the marks 331 and then what it gets back
which is the three is what it's going to
do to do its comparison and sort the
original list right so this is going to
sort by month name I'm sorry month
number so now February comes before
March comes before April and of course
we don't need to use the get indexed we
can use the on a freighter got item
Gator
so sorted month's key equals operator
I'm Gator one that's code that you might
see that kind of code exists a lot in a
lot of Python code and now even better
than before hopefully you know how to
read it
and what it's doing okay and if you want
to sort on something else well you could
do actually this we could sort on first
item Gator zero one actually returns
I hadn't known to fix this they didn't
this is yeah let's skip that because
it's kind of confusing let's just
imagine I'm not gonna type it for you
but if you change item get a one here to
item cater to and it would sort by the
number of days instead and let's get
those two okay sorry about that so your
turn to do some exercises Oh question
first no no you could use a lambda using
operator Adam Gator I would use because
it's built in library people know what
it is if they're familiar with it they
understand it right away they don't have
to parse my lambda and I'm not going to
get my lambda wrong because I won't be
using it right
what's it yep yep they have a limit you
can't do as much as with others but yeah
I would I would yes a lambda function
would work fine in that case I would
recommend use the built-in because it's
well-known and someone else already got
it right that's all okay other questions
okay go ahead and take some time working
on the exercises
okay
let's look at the exercises here splits
pretty easy m4m just to simple this
comprehension so here I'm using a nested
for and in range 3 for M in Gen ed Mar
split so I get this more complicated
thing you know just avoid them but be
aware you can do that if you want to
enumerates it kind of cool is a very
useful function especially in Python in
languages where you always have to
remember the index to iterate through
things this is why would you have a
numerator in python usually you iterate
over iterables without remember to index
because python does it for you but
sometimes you actually want to know well
how far am i my index 50 when I do this
and you new rates the easy way to do
that basically a numerate as you can see
it takes an interval consumes it and it
returns in turn pairs an iterable of
pairs where the pair is 0 a 1 B 2 C ok
and you can of course change what
happens like once you've got that end in
the C you can change it there and other
this frenzy here is these parentheses
they're optional but I think it's a
little easier to read zip is another
cool function which very much like a
zipper but not quite a zipper right
interleaves
the zip function doesn't interleave it
does pairs that's the way it works and
so zip you can take a zip pass it two
arguments and it will pair up the jan
the one the fab the to the Mar the 3 if
you pass the three arguments it'll give
you triples etc and then zip returns an
object which is iterable so we hand it
off the list
so actually we can see it what it looks
like and there we get that list so what
do you think well I thought and give us
an error in this case we've got three on
the left and four on the right the
second argument to tip and the answer is
no zip will happily stop when it
exhausts the first of its arguments as
an interval sort of like VM 100 it's
just that it's fine I'll stop before I
get 200 if you want it to stop there's
an inner
zip longest in the inner Tua's module
I don't may not be the right name but it
will stop when it gets to your lowest up
the shortest one um and again that is
can be I've used that lots it convenient
when for example I don't really care
like I have several of them and I don't
I don't even I want to maybe add an
index to one of them and I don't know
how many I'm gonna have well I'll just
put in place of the last of the one I
want the index to be I'll do a range
from zero to max and it'll only
evaluated as many as it needs and it'll
stop when it's done so I've been an
example of where it's handy to have that
functionality so there's another way to
create that list that was created
earlier right because you could take
there's the zip of three elements and
you can see I'm combining the split and
stuff like that of course here's another
way to do it
oh and here I put in look at that
there's the range of hundreds just like
I said it stops when I get to the
shortest one and there's something I
want you to try solve another one and
this one we talked to I love it Bell I'm
gonna skip most of these five minutes
right
we ended 4:40 all right so dictionaries
and sense I'm not gonna quite get
through the rest of it which is typical
I usually I put in more content to make
sure you can go look at it afterwards
dictionaries are really important
helpful a data type in Python a list is
actually a mapping is one way to think
about like remember math Venn diagram
and diagram dots in it the arrows that
map from A to B that's what I mean by a
mapping in a list maps from integer zero
to the first element it's your one to
the second element element at index 1
theta 2 etcetera and so here's an
example of right so if I take Jan Feb
Mar well that's I want I'd really like
Jan to be index element one so I put a
nun in front of it
or I could use that in Python 3 or 5 or
greater you should not come that syntax
now I've got 0 1 2 3 which is convenient
for me because 1 2 3 are the month
numbers as I think about them
all right so now I can map it I can say
well give me take an INT
turn it into a month and I get back Jan
is one high number 2 is Jan sorry number
one is Chan's number 2 is that a
dictionary is a one-to-one mapping from
anything almost it's got to be hashable
I'm not going to cover that today to any
other thing so instead of assuming the
indexed value or the key value of 0 1 2
3 etc here I have to explicitly state it
and I can't use integers if I want so
here I'm saying map 1 - Jan - to 5:30
tomorrow and then I can just say it's
month 1 2 3 networks so a dictionary is
more powerful in terms of there are more
things you can do with it it's also much
it's very fast for for searching and
finding things in ok I could do that too
instead of explicitly doing the mapping
I can do a dictionary comprehension I
think is what it's called so I sort of
looks like a list comprehension but it
kind of looks like a dictionary with a
curly brace and a colon with the key and
the value and these are variables that
are iterated over the change through
that iteration
that's know that we do and then I can
just access it right months the int so
here I'm doing month II instead of into
month they're 18 so I've got January is
month 1 etc April is 4 no it's not there
ok let's add it so this is how you
access elements of a dictionary use the
square brackets just like a list and you
pass it the key which doesn't have to
just be an int it has to be whatever key
you've defined the dictionary to have
and you can see it now as an April over
there on the end in four dictionaries is
asking the question is this key in the
dictionary is there a key value pair in
the dictionary with this key here's how
you would delete an element from the
dictionary you give it the key and
delete that you can't ever have to
duplicate keys so you don't worry about
how to figure out which one to remove
there's only gonna ever be one key tab
in a dictionary that's one of the
constraints just like months you can't
have two elements at index one there's
only one element there okay
is February in there not anymore okay do
a couple things here how to use
dictionaries dictionaries are one of the
data structures in Python that if you
haven't had them in language if you used
before you will find yourself not
reaching for them until you get to know
them and then you'll find yourself
reaching for them all the time so for
example if you want to know how many
letters there are in what are the
letters in Mississippi here would be a
way to do it so what I've done
letters is going to be dictionary with
key M will have one
what's it no no I
I'm looking for what letters are in
Mississippi right so so s is going to be
set to one four times no we're not
counting letters we're just saying what
are the letters in Mississippi okay L or
I can just look at the keys and I get
back this data structure that I can
iterate over that shows me those are the
letters here's another way to do the
same thing using addictive comprehension
there is a collections module in the
standard library that has a default deck
you can pass it a function and it will
add elements to a dictionary
on the fly so earlier with a regular
dictionary this would give me a key
error with a default dict it doesn't it
gives me a zero because it said I can't
find it so I'll call this function if
you got what to put in its place add at
the key value pair and now it's in there
so this one I could do what you were
getting at which is let's count them
right and I get the letter count right
so it added letters as needed and
incremented them so the first time it
saw the M it's stuck in well that's a
bad example
first time it's because I already did it
up here first time I saw the I had stuck
it in a zero and then incremented it
made it one next time it pulled it out
as a one it committed the to put it back
in etc and then you can look at how many
of the letters are in there there's also
a collections counter that will do this
for you and a bunch of other things and
if you only care about the keys like we
did in the first example well there's a
simpler way to do it there's a set
built-in type and you can also create
sets with a set literal like that looks
kind of like a dictionary with curly
braces but has no colon because you only
care about the keys then you can do
various operations Mississippi here oh
you're all familiar with yes Anna boy is
in my backyard so one of the two rivers
that runs through Winnipeg here's
another way to do the same thing but set
operations are pretty handy at line 687
lots of set operations ok so I can put
almost anything in a dictionary key but
not quite everything and I won't be able
to explain why but it's basically
because they have to be hashable because
if they weren't I'm about to explain why
then if you when you change the key you
can change the contents of a list then
when it goes to hash it and look it up
fast it would find it the wrong place or
not find it because it would look in the
wrong place ok
so what I did not get to show you was an
example with dictionaries which is kind
of cool
blocks and for loops iterators and
generators and a little bit about
imports calling functions etc so we got
through a fair chunk of those tutorial
and I hope it was helpful please please
please please fill out the evaluation
forms give me feedback afterwards I'm
happy with for that as well and hope you
enjoy using Python
[Applause]